we have seen a behind closed doors
demonstration of Assassin's Creed Mirage
very exciting and we also caught a
little glimpse of the Assassin's Creed
VR game Nexus which we'll also talk
about but Mirage obviously the big
tenpole Assassin's Creed release this
year it's been a couple years since we
had Valhalla uh this one is said to be a
return to the origins of the franchise
over the past few years Assassin's Creed
games
they got out of control man I love
Assassin's Creeds
um and I think they've made some really
cool changes and I've really enjoyed the
the expanded scope but it has meant that
I have not
felt as big of a connection I've
certainly not finished as many
Assassin's Creed games because I just
don't have 180 hours to do that for
every single Mainline one even though
Valhalla wasn't very much my jam and so
I think Ubisoft have heard the
complaints from a lot of people and want
to create an experience that speaks to
why people fell in love with the
franchise in the first place and that is
what they are positioning Assassin's
Creed Mirage to be yeah uh time what
were your thoughts yeah I feel like the
open world move really made sense when
they started doing it because it was a
reaction to a change in tastes and
trends like people were way more into
open world games they were more
successful you know the industry was
moving towards those kinds of games that
where people can stay there but in
continuing to make those games those
games got bigger and uh they lost almost
everything that made Assassin's Creed
unique from the old days and everything
we saw in Mirage looked like it brought
that back it was pretty much everything
that you remember from the original
games stuff like uh social stealth you
had the moment where you're sitting on
the bench and then you hire a group of
people to like blend into and then walk
into a kind of like a secluded area or a
heavily guarded area there was the the
parkour because obviously takes place in
Baghdad
um and it is a very dense sea which is
another thing that we wanted we wanted
the the open world games they stretched
so far apart that it makes parkour one
of the key aspects of Assassin's Creed
and assassins almost useless you're
running large distances or using
Vehicles especially I mean if you think
about you know about Halo Origins when
Odyssey when you're at that point it's
your parkour is basically served for
well here's a thought I'm gonna
infiltrate I'm just gonna climb up the
outside there's no real I don't even
have to run anywhere really it's nothing
it and when you look back at AC one two
you know there were puzzles tied to
parkour it was interesting you couldn't
climb everything but you could climb a
lot
and so this feels it looks like it has a
much nicer balance of the tune yeah a
much denser environment and City and
they said there's outside of the the
core Baghdad area there is a more open
space that you can explore Baghdad
itself is very dense in a way that it's
clearly you can see that they've layered
in the architecture to make it as
conducive to platforming and parkour and
they have brought back things like the
corner swing that they had in a while
back yeah that's like the cool slide
slide the crossover grab like the stuff
that was classically Assassin's Creed is
back and that is really really exciting
for me as someone who and and you and a
lot of people they'll be seeing that and
thinking like oh the stuff that made
people excited about Assassin's Creed is
back and immediately there's a kind of
like bassim is a street kid for a long
time and then he has a run-in with the
assassins and it kind of changes the
trajectory of his life and it also
doesn't seem that he's sort of following
the Assassins without question he's very
much
unsure he's unsure because like he is
he's a I believe a thief but he doesn't
have a proper family or Community there
are other thiefs but they're ultimately
thieves they're like a you know a
sporadic group of people the Assassins
are more built around a family or a unit
or that kind of thing so I think that's
what they're trying to set up as is
pulling them but as he kind of leans
more into that his friends from The
Thief side are like the the freedom that
you are given now comes with
unquestionably following what you're
told and it's like he's giving up
freedom but he's getting a family but
he's losing you know his other family
who want him to maintain some of his
freedom there's other things like the
the whole thing where you build up bases
again I don't know you're building your
assassins uh Hideout hideouts yeah
there's contracts to take out yep and
you're like trying to establish bases in
more places it's not quite like the the
estate thing from ac2 as far as I know
where you're like building new areas and
stuff I think it's like just you go
around establish a base and then kind of
clean up the area but as well they were
saying that you know you pick
you pick up contracts and there's a
smaller things
and they and they have the great thing
that I loved in ac2 which was okay do
this Mission but don't take damage or
don't be seen and I would love these
kind of optional objectives
um and they were saying that the the big
assassinations you know again the big
story driven stuff uh those are gonna be
like the black box missions that they
introduced with unity I believe yeah
Unity kind of more figure out how you
want to do this yeah figure out your
approach the Hitman like stuff basically
yeah there's that and then uh bassim has
like a bunch of tools available to him
yeah obviously he's got the melee stuff
he's got the blow door and and a few
other things as well smoke bombs Etc
traps the thing that they said that I
was really excited by was that actual
combat is your last resort yeah which I
think Assassin's Creed very recently was
the other way it was you know nothing to
do with self nothing really do with your
toolkit it was just gonna Mash yeah and
that was a necessity tied to the RPG
system where you needed experience and
growth and as far as I can tell that
wasn't in here there was no like crazy
like oh kill this Thing 2 XP or whatever
it may be and otherwise the combat seems
largely familiar they have added one new
move which I believe is called the
Assassin's Focus oh which was a very
interesting thing where because he's a
street Thief uh blasium is able to move
so quickly that to everyone else it
almost looks like he's teleporting and
to him it feels like time is slowing
down so what he does what you do is you
enter this mode it's like you basically
Mark and kill mark and execute which is
a
Splinter Cell move which is upsetting to
me as someone who's waiting for Splinter
Cell but it's literally Sam Fisher's
Mark and execute where you go Bam Bam
Bam and then bust him basically just
like teleport in a cinematic way behind
one does the hidden blade behind the
other like moves between them and then
you just see all of them just drop yep
and you're like done I'm out
um it looks like there are limitations
on when and how much you can do that you
can't just Spam it obviously but that
was a cool new wrinkle that I had not
seen in Assassin's Creed and ultimately
it's also a cool wrinkle because it
Embraces the weirdness of Assassin's
Creed where it's like the the animation
for it isn't like him sprinting it's
like the Animus teleport where he's like
ghost Fades out and then like he's
almost like the Animus is moving him
around but
I love that idea again where they're
like it's not so based on like super
realism and the anime stuff is like you
know segregated it's like it's in the
game itself like you remember when they
used to have like the glitches in the
world where it'd be like people would
fade in and out and like render and
unrender and when you did something
they'll be like this wave of like a
deformation of visuals and it was like
oh yeah they're doing this assassin
stuff again it's quintessentially
assassins it remains to be seen whether
it's a good game
it's hitting the right note to me in
this sort of preview phase this behind
closed doors phase where the things that
I have fallen out of love with
Assassin's Creed uh with are gone and
they're bringing back the stuff that
helped me fall in love with the
franchise exactly but we also saw a
little look at Nexus which is the
Assassin's Creed VR game one of the
worst kept secrets in uh video game
development um
the thing is they address this in you
see you can it's first person it's kind
of going through uh it's actually a
pretty cool concept three is Cassandra
it's Altair and Ezio oh yes
it looks like Altair though which makes
sense because they're yeah
uh and so what's happening is basically
abstergo because they've been monitoring
you they have all the information about
you possible and they can use that to
make you they can use your own thoughts
to control you into voting a certain way
for example or doing something that they
want you to do they're trying to find
the three pieces of not eating but I
thought it was the apple of Eden that's
basically one of those mind control
devices and they know
each one piece of it is in each of these
assassins Generations so they're trying
to figure out where that is so they can
go grab it so I'm really intrigued by
the premise really good there's a bunch
of stuff that's in first person I think
in terms of VR implementation you know
they were saying oh you're always on
your back or your knives are on your
belt and you have to swing hidden blade
yeah and you do have to get the hidden
blade out however as soon as I saw that
footage
I just I I won't be able to play that it
makes me feel ill just thinking about it
however they said it's been completely
designed with VR sensitivity
comfortability they said the
comfortability is what they use so
there's teleportation movement as well
vignetting but I mean if I'm gonna be
parkouring that's that's gonna be a real
test for them and so I don't want to
write it off completely I do want to
give it a go but as someone with pretty
intense VR Sensitivity I was like I I
could do the fighting stuff it's the
parkour that I am yeah so they talked
about one I think one of the main things
that they talked about obviously with
the vignetting and like making more like
focal points and landmarks for your eyes
to like oh if you're afraid of heights
yes yeah and they have like uh a system
for if you're afraid of heights which I
imagine is like kind of just like making
it hard to see stuff lower to the ground
or something like that but the thing is
I am not 100 sure of how indicative of
the gameplay experience the video we saw
was because they were moving like
assassins in first person like
seamlessly from point to point to point
I do not know how that is gonna be okay
like it is one from a actual control
perspective that's going to be very
tricky it's not a meta Quest
um I like I've not seen a game that
allows you to move with the fluidity
that they showed I've not I don't
understand how you would input that
um the closest I've been to a played to
the experience it looks to be presenting
is Horizon call of the mountain which is
PlayStation VR2 I review that game
it is perhaps the most advanced movement
based game with the climbing and they're
kind of running around and dashing and
that kind of stuff even that has like
stop and start movement and it allows
you to take it at a certain pace
it does not look like the way this
Assassin's game looked where you were
like leaping from point to point around
the corner and down dropping into a
haystack and then running forward
I'm someone who gets very emotion sick I
was like no shot there's no shot unless
that's a trailer that is just showing
the idealized vision I think if I played
it it would be like I'm gonna teleport
to this point and then I'm gonna
teleport to this point and then when I
wait and I'm gonna teleport this point
not the fluidity that they showed off
maybe there are people out there that
are capable of like doing all this stuff
in first person and not feeling sick but
his business where he's like leaping off
things and rolling and like that's what
Assassin's doing I was like okay I'll
take your word for it good luck for you
good luck to you but again it's an
intriguing concept as you said story
interested to see the execution maybe
they have some sort of wild and unused
and completely new way to
deal with motion sickness for this kind
of game and that we don't know that
makes it do able to play assassins in
that way but
I can't think of it and I hope I'm
interested to see what it is yeah yeah
me too for more on Assassin's Creed
obviously keep your eyes pl2 Gamespot
will have plenty more in the run-up to
the launch of Assassin's Creed Mirage